la parole à Monsieur alberériic de
montolfier pour le groupe UMP merci
merci merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Madame la Ministre chargée de la
décentralisation et elle porte bien
évidemment bien évidemment sur le projet
de loi de réforme des collectivités et
également sur ses conséquences sur nos
budgets locaux puisque face aux
multiples protestation dans les rang de
la majorité mais également à l'approche
de quelques échéances électorales le
gouvernement a décidé
lors du conseil des ministres d'hier de
scinder le projet le premier projet en
trois textes qui portent respectivement
sur les métropole sur les régions et sur
les solidarités
territoriales ce saucissonnage du texte
sur la décentralisation est critiqué sur
de nombreux rangs y compris par le
président de la commission des lois que
je vois ici et je le cite qui dénonçait
dès le premier projet un objet
législatif allant dans tous les sens et
accordant des compétences à géométrie
variaable et qui a regretté monsieur
monsieur le Président la semaine
dernière qui a regretté sur ces ban la
semaine dernière ce découpage ces trois
textes accordent madame la ministre la
priorité dans le calendrier
préarlementaire une priorité aux
métropoes nos communes nos départements
seront donc évoqués en dernier madame
les ministres en donnant la priorité aux
métropoles et aux grandes agglomérations
vous risquez de faire reposer le
développement du pays sur le seul fait
urbain l'Assemblée des départements de
France qui est d'ailleurs prés ésidé par
un élu de votre majorité condamne un
texte là aussi citation qui considère
nos territoire comme un sujet annexe par
ailleurs le gouvernement a annoncé la
baisse des dotations 4 milards 500
millions d'euros auquel il faut ajouter
c une estimation la DG C 800 millions
d'euros de moins pour au titre des
normes un groupe de travail du comité
des finances locales s d'ailleurs réuni
au Sénat ce matin mais pour évoquer
cette question mais comment répondre à
cette question de la baisse des
dotations alors même que nous ne
connaissons pas à ce stade les futures
compétences comme l'a très justement
souligné Éric deligliger mon voisin
aujourd'hui le premier texte à étudier
aurait dû être celui de la clarification
et de la simplification des compétences
alors que les élus locaux avaient
condamné cel cas dans les états généraux
la décentralisation avait condamné la
complexification croissant des textes
quelle est la cohérence du séquenage de
cette nouvelle réforme comment nos
concitoyens comment les élus peuvent-ils
comprendre les annonces multiples
parfois contradictoires du gouvernement
quel est enfin le calendrier exact de la
réforme de ces texte et en particulier
le calendrier de l'examen du dernier
texte qui sera consacré aux communes et
au départements madame la ministre je
crois que les élus ont besoin de clarté
merci madame Anne-Marie escaufier
ministre chargée de la
décentralisation monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur de
Mongolfier les questions la question que
vous vous venez de me poser me donne
l'occasion de vous apporter des réponses
aussi précises que possible sur l'état
des travaux que nous avons conduit
d'abord peut-être préciser que la
volonté du gouvernement une volonté
affirmée déterminée c'est d'aller vers
un texte qui soit un texte de
clarification un texte d'efficacité un
texte de maîtrise des dépenses trois
objectifs que nous avons inscrits dans
ce texte avec la volonté de toujours le
faire dans le cadre d'une véritable
concertation d'un vrai dialogue que nous
avons voulu avec vous dans le cadre des
états généraux de la démocratie
territoriale mais aussi avec l'ensemble
de nos élus partenaires et qui nous ont
apporter des éclairages tout à fait
indispensables alors le texte qui a été
présenté en Conseil des ministres vous
dites saucissonné monsieur le sénateur
non je ne reprendrai pas le mot je dis
que nous avons un texte unique un texte
qui est un vrai pacte un Pact de la
démocratie un pacte de décentralisation
et de réforme de l'action publique qui
ne dissocie pas les collectivités
territoriales de l'État mais qui apporte
cette cohérence
indispensable pour que l'action publique
tout ensemble est un véritable sens pour
les citoyens un texte donc dont je dis
de clarification d'efficacité de
maîtrise des dépenses et j'y viens parce
que la maîtrise des dépenses est un
objectif auquel nous sommes tous
attachés nous avons dit l'effort et
toutes les collectivités ont accepté de
participer à cet effort lors d'une
réunion tenue par le Premier ministre le
12 mars dernier une réunion au cours de
laquelle nous avons inscrit les
principes d'impacte de confiance et de
responsabilité pacte que nous écrirons
ensemble et qui permettra de mesurer
dans les dotations comment faire les
économies qui doivent être des économies
à hauteur de 1illard 500 millions c'est
vrai pour l'année 2014 repris en 2015 un
effort sur lequel nous essaierons de
faire de faire peser sur l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales en veillant
à ce que la péréquation serve l'intérêt
des moins des des moins favorisé par
rapport au plus favorisés rien ne nous
échappera dans ce travail ni sur les
dotations ni sur la pééquation ni sur la
fiscalité je veux vous assurer en tout
cas de la détermination très forte qui
est la nôtre de faire en sorte que les
textes que nous attendons et dont nous
avons besoin puissent intervenir dans
tous les cas c'est notre objectif avant
les élections prochaines de l'année 2014
pour le premier et le 2è texte il nous
faut y parvenir avant la fin de cette
année voilà les ass vous apporté
monsieur le sénate merci